les premiers rayons de soleil du
printemps vous rappellent aussi qu'il
faudra vite trouver de quoi
occuper vos petits cet été votre garçon
cet été
et cette année vous devrez possiblement
débourser plus d'argent pour
l'inscription j'ai pas compris mais je
sais que ça j'ai vu que ça a monté de
catégorie de prix je fais les recherches
puis je vais voir où est-ce qu'on peut
aller parce que j'ai trois enfants
que c'est beaucoup moins cher que ça
paraît de la fin mars à joindre le
dernier roche pour nous l'été est là
c'est la période des inscriptions pour
Eric Jenny qui est propriétaire de deux
contes jours le prix de la facture
augmenté d'environ 6% cette année
des employés où tu avais finalement
trouvé tout le monde c'est que les
moniteurs sont de plus en plus
difficiles à recruter le salaire offert
a aussi fait un bon de 6%. parce que mon
salaire le plus
conscient de l'impact d'une télo sur le
portefeuille des parents
Eric tignetzky tente de s'adapter ça
vient des milliers dans l'ordre nous on
a commencé à étaler vraiment les
paiements sur plusieurs plusieurs mois
là on est rendu à ils peuvent faire
jusqu'à 6 paiements
étalé sur 6 mois pour essayer des aider
justement la situation et la même dans
la plupart des camps de la province on a
vu des organisations des salades qui ont
grimpé trois dollars de l'heure on sait
la première fois qu'on voit qu'il y a un
rattrapage de cette intensité là au
niveau des cas le service est essentiel
pour la plupart des familles plus d'aide
gouvernementales serait bienvenus
en général vont avoir besoin de plus
d'aide de ce côté-là entre temps il
rappelle aux familles que le service
donne droit à un crédit d'impôt un
retour d'argent qui peut soulager le
portefeuille des parents ici qui me
permettra de Canada MONT